last time you were on um you met octavia
spencer
yeah so have you seen her since oh my
god i
first off i cannot say more positive
things about a person than octavia
spencer i i
i had no idea i i had no idea i was just
going to completely fall in love with
her i i ran into her
at um it was like an oscars party or
something i don't know how i got in but
i was there
and it was like a bun it was a bunch of
different actors and
um and octavia was there like in a group
with like some pretty big actors like
like
big actors and and i was like okay i'm
gonna go in i'm gonna say hi to activity
i'm gonna seem
so cool because we know each other so i
go in and and i say hi to her she says
hi she gives me a hug it's like it's
like
best friends reunited um and i'm like
this is going great and then
and then like i you know i talked to the
other actors there and i'm like i'm like
i'm like really flowing like my
conversation is going right now like i'm
doing a good job
so i'm like wow i'm probably gonna get
like a big movie deal after this this is
nuts
i'm networking king and then as i and i
say goodbye to octavia and i'm walking
away
and one of one of the actors calls me
over and goes hey can you come here for
a second and i'm like oh my god
this is my big break and and he goes and
he goes he whispers in my ear and he
goes
uh your fly is down put your zipper up
and i oh no
yeah that's the worst the entire time i
thought i was being so cool
i had my fly down the entire time that
is like my life in a nutshell
it's the worst that's honestly these
guys are laughing so much and it's
because they were laughing at me
i know well they probably weren't
everybody has stuff like that that
happens but
it's the best it takes a lot of courage
to tell somebody
especially when like like when i i
actually never have the courage to tell
anybody like when my friend has food on
their mouth or like somebody i don't
know like there's food on their mouth i
have such a hard time going hey get the
food i don't know why but it's such an
embarrassing car i am the first person
to tell you if you have a booger
your pants are unzipped something's
happening
first person i have no because i want
people to tell me because
i mean obviously we're all human and
stuff happens right right right
but yeah burgers always yeah natalie my
friend my assistant like literally
always tells me i'm a booger so
yeah i'm just like you got something get
it and i'm like you know yeah
but it's the booger it's fine we'll move
on it'll be fine